what a crazy weekend uh it's good to be
back and there's so much to talk about
we have a big media story
free speech story censorship story
actually it's really just a media story
advertisers are fleeing
fox news propagandist tucker carlson's
program
why because of constantly racially
charged and quite frankly
boring and predictable nonsense that is
totally toxic and right away
the whole i don't really understand the
first amendment
crowd is out in force defending tucker
carlson against
second uh i'm sorry first amendment not
second amendment
first amendment misunderstandings and
so-called charges of censorship but what
we're actually seeing
is the marketplace of ideas that these
right-wingers claim to want and i'm
going to get to that a little bit later
after explaining to you what took place
being associated with tucker carlson's
program is bad for some advertisers
in the marketplace and they are making
the decision to bail
so just the other day tucker carlson
said on his show the protests
aren't really about black lives and that
ominously
they will come for you it wasn't clear
when he said it if he met black people
or who
later claimed that he meant oh no
democrats i guess here's what he had to
say
this may be a lot of things this moment
we're living through but it is
definitely
not about black lives and remember that
when they come for you and at this rate
they will
anyone's ever been subjected to the rage
of the mob knows the feeling it's like
being swarmed by hornets you cannot
think clearly
a bunch of companies that had been
advertising on tucker carlson's program
decided to pull their advertising
because of that and other clips it
wasn't just
one thing apparently this includes
disney
this includes papa john's pizza which is
historically a horrible company a
t-mobile poshmark and some other
brands so in a second we're going to
talk about the free speech and
censorship component to this because the
misunderstandings that are floating
around
are disturbing in terms of the lack of
understanding of
anything related to speech and
censorship that they that they portray
but i want to be really like extra
super clear about something here i said
this is just business and this is just
business it's a market
decision that's being made by these
companies papa john's
said they are deciding to stop all
advertising on opinion shows in general
it's not
that they're particularly upset with
what tucker said they're making a
business decision to pull advertising
from all opinion programs the other
advertisers
are the papa john's and other
advertisers they're not bailing on fox
news
there are they're they're they're not
saying the problem is that
fox is so hair brained that they allow
tucker carlson a platform to say this
stuff
they're just moving from tucker carlson
to other fox news shows that are less
under the microscope
fox news said that these departures
aren't causing a financial hit because
it's just moving money from tucker's
show
to other shows so these are not
political decisions
in general in the sense that these are
companies that are still okay sending
money to fox news
and they are okay with fox news carrying
water in general
for donald trump and the terrible ideas
espoused by donald trump
uh uh and by the network but they're not
going to do it on tucker carlson's show
because it's just become
a negative attention getter so to speak
so now that gets us to the first
amendment
free speech component which for me is
really the most interesting thing
a whole bunch of trump-supporting
right-wingers are saying
this is censorship of tucker carlson
there's
a free speech violation first amendment
you know fill in the blanks with your
generic
censorship contr concerned trolling
language
and then let's debunk these claims one
by one first of all
this has nothing to do with the first
amendment this is
the participants here are advertisers
a tv channel and the tv host and the
audience
first amendment is not a factor here the
government is not abridging anyone's
speech whatsoever so first amendment
into the trash out the window second
this is how capitalism and the
marketplace of ideas works
understand that there's no coercion
happening here
there's you know the the non-aggression
principle people should be pleased
tucker carlson can choose i guess he's
allowed
to say whatever he wants on his program
uh
and that may have repercussions fox news
is totally
free no coercion fox news can choose to
employ tucker or not
they may have a particular contract with
them where if they pull them off the air
they still got to pay them but
they and tucker carlson agreed on that
contract with no government intervention
advertisers can choose to advertise on
any show they want or not to
for any reason they can say i don't like
the uh
the suits that tucker carlson wears or i
don't like what tucker carlson says
they are free to decide however they
want to or not to advertise on any
particular program
viewers like you can choose
to watch or not watch tucker carlson
viewers can
choose to contact advertisers and say
if you advertise with tucker i will no
longer buy your stuff or they could say
unless you advertise with tucker i won't
buy your stuff everybody's free to do
whatever they want
period and interestingly the advertiser
can choose again non-aggression no
coercion
if you're an advertiser and people start
writing to you saying you'd better stop
advertising with tucker or
you'd better start advertising with
tucker either way the advertiser can
choose to listen to those people
or not everybody gets to make their
choices now you're going to hear some
people pop up
and they are they're either ignorant or
they're concerned trolling
and they will say if you email a company
and say
i will not buy your stuff if you do x or
y like advertising with tucker
that's coercion it's not coercion it's
called
speech there's no violence it's a
marketplace
this is literally what the free
marketeers claim to want
i as a buyer can choose to buy or not
buy a product for any reason
that is important to me i as a buyer am
free to tell a company why i am buying
their product
or why i am not buying their product and
the company
can choose whether to pay attention to
me or whether to tell me to go to hell
and do whatever they want
the company can decide you know if we
advertise with tucker
we're gonna lose a thousand customers
but we might gain two thousand because
his audience
is so big and that extra thousand
customers
is worth it to us despite the pr problem
that it might cause us
to advertise with tucker carlson and
they can decide whatever they want
the market is actually regulating itself
here
without violence or government
intervention the right wingers
should be cheering this but they're not
they want to frame it
as a liberal mob trying to hurt
someone's ability to earn a living we
don't even know by the way
whether tucker's income is affected by
the number of advertisers his show has
it may not be we don't know
they are pathetic and they are
predictable and they're so boring i mean
we're it's just it's getting so old that
they either
don't understand or pretend not to
understand how markets and free speech
and censorship
actually work if you love feeding
your intellectual curiosity but you're
always struggling to find the time
check out one of my all-time favorite
apps called
blinkist blinkist lets you consume an
entire book
on your way home from work they take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
condense each one into text or audio
that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important
core ideas and information from that
book it's perfect
if you don't have enough time to do all
the reading you want to do
or if you just want to sample a book
before you buy the entire thing
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic to check it out on blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription
is only about eight bucks a month and
you get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
pacman i've put the link right
underneath this video